no matter where you're from to be
nominated for an Academy Award is to
become part of the community the film
music of the past 90 years is part of
our popular culture encouraging us to
lift our voices with passion sometimes
in praise
sometimes in protests the efforts of
this year's nominated writers reflect a
variety of backgrounds and musical
styles they've provided stirring anthems
a poetic meditation on love a
celebration of folklore and pointed
social observations once again here are
the nominees for Best Original Song
mighty river from mud band music and
lyric by mary j blige Raphael Saadiq
antara Stinson
mystery of love from call me by your
name music and lyric by Sufjan Stevens
[Music]
remember me from cocoa music and lyrics
by Kristen anderson-lopez and Robert
Lopez
stand up for something from Marshall
music by Diane Warren lyric by Lonnie
Amin and Diane one this is me from the
greatest show music Americ by Benj
passive and justin poll and the Oscar
goes to
Mickey goal Kristen anderson-lopez in
Robert
nomination for Kristen and
for the song
[Applause]
we were gonna go for the jetski but
we're from Brooklyn so here we go
thank you guys Thank You Academy I
really want to take a minute to look at
this category of incredible nominated
songwriters tonight not only are we
diverse but we are close to 5050 for
gender representation when you're
looking at category like ours
it helps us imagine a world where all
the categories look like this one thanks
Lee Darla and everyone at Pixar for
letting us be a part of this important
celebration of Mexico music and family
thanks to everyone who worked on and
performed the song and a shout out to
our frozen Broadway family on Broadway
that's just finished with some previews
most of all we thank our family the
Andersons
and the Lopezes and our daughters Katie
and Annie who are here with us tonight
inspire everything we do but this is not
for you this is for my mom who passed
away everyone who knew her will always
remember her
[Applause]